[Music]
as sine patches Mar countless fields in
the James River Valley and continue to
grow Farmers have had to retreat from
what may have been their best ground
only a few decades ago the sine
phenomenon continues its Relentless
course UPS slope in fields robbing the
land of its productivity draining
Farmers pocketbooks leaving many to feel
helpless in the face of this tidal wave
of rising Waters and Sals two brothers
in Beetle County South Dakota decided
that business as usual was not an option
in the face of this
threat hi I'm Bose Clute and I'm a
scientist but this is not my story to
really understand the Hamilton's Journey
we have to begin here
about mid 80s our land at Arlington we
used to drive a two wheel drive 165
horsepower tractor over there to farm
and the one year we had a lot of rain
and we're driving driving down a County
Road and we're driving through a couple
inches of water and I thought like
everybody else well you know what it was
a wet year next year the weather pattern
will change and that water will go away
well 5 years went by 10 years went by
and that road didn't come back above
water that road that I used to drive the
two wheel drive tractor down has 25 plus
feet of water over the top of
it I'm Scott Hamilton I'm Jeff Hamilton
I'm Scott's brother we have a mixed
cropping mixed livestock operation we
grow corn soybeans elf
ala we're integrating Rye we've messed
around some cover crops uh also using
some Japanese Millet uh as a way to try
to clean up some Fields without
chemistry we're actually in five
different counties and we try and
incorporate our cow herd and cattle back
through all our cropping
Acres when I was in school I remember my
dad saying you always grow some wheat
some small grain cuz you never know if
you're going to get enough rain for
corn and when soybeans started coming in
out here that would have been early '
80s early 80s um and then that's sort of
when these West these potholes in the
state started filling with water
yeah so yeah it it it was after probably
in the 90s for the most part was the
biggest change you know
[Music]
so we have a cropping field that it's
been corn soy beans maybe back in time
it had some wheat of course with our
weather change over the years it had the
last I don't know probably last what 15
years we haven't raised anything there
in fact it was getting so bad well the
kosher weed we didn't grow is pure
saline it it would typically be wet in
the spring you'd try to if you try to
work it disc it or chisel it and after
we got out of that after we started
noing you'd swing the boom out there and
kill it and
so if you tried to disc it you would
plant it and you'd grow nothing so you
had to hope you didn't get stuck and
then you go in there and you disc it and
then you'd prevent PL it collect your
government crop insurance check and it's
like we can't just keep doing this yeah
I economically I make make sense but the
land was going backwards
[Music]
for me it started with the sing areas I
got tired of growing nothing and it
might L with the crop insurance CU
you'll be able to collect your prevent
plant for the first few years but once
you're so far into it then you're
getting zero production you know it's
it's a it's a short-term gain is what it
is shortterm short-term gain but if
we're truly if we're truly stewards of
the land we can't do things from a
short-term gain
standpoint well I took and went and
bought some saline seed mix or it was
mostly blend the wheed
grasses um made sure it was pretty weed
clean cuz uh barley foxtail would be the
first thing it would start so we sprayed
it with Roundup got it clean I think we
SE it in June and by that fall I had I
could Row the grass which I could not
believe because it had not grown
anything for
[Music]
years we
were was experimenting with just seeding
a
single blend of grass and that didn't
really seem to work so we started
working with a blend that would we could
get into the saline sodic
spots and just sort of experimented back
and forth and we came up with this blend
that uh this Seed Company calls the
Hamilton the blend is uh has some wheat
grasses in it it has a Garrison creeping
fox tail um it has a little bit of I
think they're putting a little bit of
fescue in it and then we also have some
slendy Max or a saline Al Alpha that can
stand with sand saline areas
[Music]
well when we first was working with that
seed blend I wanted to put a mix in
there so a lot of times it's difficult
to get in to seed those due to being too
wet or so forth or so on and I had
seeded monocultures and if I had the
wrong weather event I would end up
losing everything so I what by putting
multiple species in there if it was too
saline uh then the wheat grasses would
take over if it was too sodic The
Garrison creep and fox tail and and
maybe the Fescue and Reeds would take
over and and with the the alala in there
what'll happen is is the wheat grasses
will go in those saline areas then that
here comes the great the the slendy Max
or the saline elf Alpha will start
fallowing that in and they complement
each other so if you have alphalpha
there plus the grass you have a legume
growing some nitrogen and enhances your
forage production um if you cut it three
times your first cutting will be half
cool season half half Alpha then your
second cutting will be mostly all
alphaalpha if you cut it the third time
it'll sort of be half and half but by
having that together uh you're covering
all your bases and the soil
types uh determine which species Grows
Where
[Music]
we started doing business with a a guy
that is very good at delineating soil
types uh because we are extremely
variable and when I say extremely
variable uh we can go from Z to 150
bushel yield difference in corn and we
do that in 150 ft and we do that
multiple times across a half mile path
of our field as we've changed our and
new technologies that are available to
us uh I started VAR aberrating my seed I
we kept Vari brating my
fertilizer um kept looking at these
areas and we started planting these
saling areas back to the Hamilton blend
3 four five acres at a time and since
2016 uh probably two years ago we'd
probably done 150 acres at that time uh
we've done more since
[Music]
the first step in recovering and is
first of all you have to make a change
and to the change that was the easiest
to make for us is to stop spraying those
areas well yeah you have to change your
attitude you have to change your mindset
you got to I do all the spraying so you
have to make sure you save those
spaces or don't spray them and and you
know be cognizant of your wind and so
forth and and care and try you
know in some Fields we've we've had
we're in the third year of not spraying
the sloos the Rye is a good way to amend
that
soil uh and it helps with your weed
control Japanese Millet will grow into
the sine salinity areas further than the
Rye will um both of those plants have a
phenomenal root system on them
uh going back to that kosha plant you
know the areas that didn't grow kosha
the next step when you stop spraying it
is we'll we'll have a stunted kosher
plant it'll be a grayish color and it
gets about this tall and never really
changes well next year you'll turn that
that kosha plant some of those areas
will turn into a dark green koser well
part of that is is you got to have those
plant species there that are putting
rots down that are putting EX down which
create your biology in your soil or your
Livestock in your soil then you can
start doing things if we just get out of
Mother Nature's Way She will fix herself
I'm convinced of that we're in the
process of trying to trying to actually
prove
[Music]
that if we can get kosha growing we can
use utilize livestock to harvest kosher
actually cattle really at a vegetative
state really like kosher
and kosha is your first step of maybe
barley fox tail livestock don't like
that so much but barley fox tail might
provide a a cover for seeding inter
seeding your grass seed into you know as
as a livestock and crop Farmers hay is a
crop and a lot of people strictly crop
farming don't consider hay a crop and so
you have to sort of change your mental
capacity and we're always looking for
forage and those areas well we're where
we've had the Hamilton we're doing 3 to
3 and 1/2 ton an acre on Acres that
weren't producing
[Music]
anything but the other thing is is when
we're seating This Grass blend is we
make the mistake of just going to the
edge of the salt actually we need you
make need to make three runs into the up
plan by doing that that so saine place
will fill in faster than just
concentrating on it so if you can take
your good land and sacrifice three
passes with a drill that'll enhance your
recovery a lot
more so if we can get uh if we can get
these plant species established in the
Upland and they're more mature they'll
handle the higher salt levels and saline
levels and then that way Our Roots will
just start leading the others in
there from a wildlife species
standpoint and it takes all the pressure
out of it because if he's spraying it
where where are our trouble wheat
they're growing in the areas
where where we can't grow a crop well
and even the going back to the hunting
or Wildlife you know it's really it's
tough hunting in a standing corn field
especially in 30in rows what's really
great is if you can push them out of the
cornfield into the saline spots that
we've got this perennial grass and you
have a great deer hunt or a great
pheasant hunt you know or Grouse or
whatever um you know that's another
thing is those saline areas that are put
to a plant species sort to become our
pollinator
you know so they have bugs which
pheasants like or other game um you know
there's another species of of animals or
insects that complement our whole
biology you
know you know you can have the best of
both worlds you can have something that
you can uh the cattle will like and and
for me the pheasant hunting and the hay
is important but really for me it became
a joy of watching a piece of soil that
did not grow anything it would not grow
a corn plant it would not grow a soybean
plant when go crocher we and and yes and
and now we're
growing very desirable plants we did
this without external fertilizer being
used and we did it without uh chemical
because there isn't a chemical We can
spray on you manage it by haying it you
can manage it by grazing it there's
better ways to do it than hey my planet
is this big and I want a square
[Music]
field I hope the Hamilton story has
helped you view salinity differently the
good news is that South Dakota has the
expertise to turn these Acres around
using natural
systems but this will take some thought
some time and some
planning visit this video description
below for more information and remember
like planting a tree the best time to
address salinity was 20 years ago the
second best time is today from growing
resilience I'm bz Clute so long
[Music]